welcome to this video covering Tata
Steel 2014 around six and um I must
confess that I'm having some problems
with those videos simply because it's
six games I cover them all and the
player simply failed to produce any any
boring game sets about that again
dispatch two or three games quickly and
concentrate more on the on the more
complicated and interesting ones they
simply m play quite quite interesting
games all of them and this is the case
in this round as well so um I'd like to
keep the videos at least below one hour
so on some of it will be done quite
quickly to focus on some some main
points let let's start with a kayak and
play wide against an itouch and
connecting play Knight f3 and g3 slight
surprise his own well-known 1.e4 play
and he has excellent score with the four
but nowadays people like to branch out
of it and very their openings to not be
so predictable yeah deform here reversed
groom thought I was a bit surprised by
this move order because it's it's quite
uncommon to play d4 exactly here but
Darren I did show is ignores the
opportunity could have taken here the
point is that after we capture black is
able to play e5 and there's nothing to
capture on c6 like in the groom felt
this is actually quite nice for black um
maybe you would have played castles but
I don't know it's a bit strange that
knowledge didn't take okay now we have a
regular let's say reverse groom fault if
you watch my Blitz videos you you see
that opening once in a while
e 6 and ce4 end this now can transpose
to various openings after there should
be seven for example we would have the
tirage defense to the Queens gambit but
knowledge is not going for that any
place d take c form and this infection
supposes to the open catalan usually
reach via d 49 f 64 e 6 g 3 now that I'm
valid main line 95 this is the most
aggressive way to play one point being
that night XD for is a little trapped
because of III and like has a problem
that needs to move the light check then
check just loses the rock in the corner
so now Texas is bad this is also bad
because well white can also I black can
also take first it's not a huge
difference and now I'm the snide oops 93
coming with this threads and what will
we gain the poem this is very nice for
white actually yeah it it's Bishop d7
the main move and now night a three so
we have a gambit continuation like has
won the default point for the moment but
we see that in this type of position why
it has an excellent development both
bishops are nicely placed and there's
the Queen also joining the game later um
yeah here in this position night it's
funny enough is going for novelty this
has been played like 100 times before
but no one ever went 95 it looks
perfectly normal this move but I have
added found didn't find any game with it
it's not such a small database that I
have a bit a bit strange I'm not sure
that this is a really a great novelty
but
normally black castles him we see that
after 97 Queen d7 95 this was not the
only option but certainly a good line
that kayaking chose here take stakes
it's very logical yeah black will lose
the d4 pawn back no way to do to keep it
on the move like let's say Knight f6 to
keep the pawn for the moment queen bee
three is just a very strong reply and
black has no way to cover b7 root b 8
that's the bishop so not a good move
black just needs to give the phone back
and this is what he did castles and we
reach this position oops yeah well okay
do this let's play let's move out on the
board Queen B 5 yeah this is the best
that I can hope for after the 95 new
move I think he really is somehow
stumbled into this line it's not a
prepared or not nobody i think if this
is the best you mean I mean white will
take and he did take we get this
isolated queen palm position with only
heavy pieces on the board and this is
just a terrible torture for black it's a
position that probably most of the times
black will not lose but if you will
never ever win a game and you will lose
some it's just a matter of constant
pressure being applied and we can
progress a couple of moves and see that
just just typical game is proceeding
where black is tied to the defense of
the pawn and white is combining threats
against this pawn with other play he's
some
sometimes able for example to use this
rook lifting it why this is always
always better and can try little things
in repeating once or twice it does not
hurt showing black that you're the boss
in the game that you're the one calling
the shots of it's a draw or not so
always a useful tool the a pattern you
can you can improve the position here he
tries to play at the right moment before
dislodging the rookie and then gain the
d5 pawn this is all quite quite normal
g6 canvas the f5 square because Queen f5
always want an annoyance however in this
position where gap everything up to now
um get developed rather slowly are you
wide had a nice technical opportunity or
let's say a concrete opportunity i'm not
sure if you really should call it
tactical here why he played Queen d2
which is very normal looking move
attacking a five keeping the pressure on
and it keeps a an edge no doubt he
righted a strong we could play he for
him this is a bit counterintuitive just
playing before and allowing black to get
rid of this pawn but it's just a
concrete line if black takes and this
instantly losses I mean I think black is
lost anyway but this is instantly losing
because of GTA check King moves and
queen d 4 + okay black can insert a
check if he wants check like that but
now he needs to attend to the maid
threat or gadget buddhism meet and the
funny thing is that after something like
f6 check will check and now simply
rookie seven
the screen d8 made this a threat and
black has no way to do prevent that
again cannot stop the maid you can play
route d5 but then queen a7 is coming and
it's a it's a deadly attack on the same
rank that's really funny details before
is just losing straightaway other lines
are very very similar check like back f6
okay group t7 here this is another
important line of course including the
Queen so black after if ye cannot take
and this means white is winning the pawn
and also the game probably because it's
such a strong extra point in the center
that is pushing forward immediately so
this would have won the game I think
Queen d2 it's just keeping the position
as is but not really a winning as such
yeah we have the Sun this trade and now
white centralizing he sort of had the
idea obviously but somehow didn't didn't
find e-form yakeen age 7 and white has
this veteran rang REM of course to gets
a play against the king he's in this
somewhat uncomfortable pin but black has
no way to use it yeah took on age five
check yeah this is so nice little threat
who gets heavy in general I thank you
after kayaking check failed to find this
before move after that knowledge is
putting up a really great resistance
yeah it's absolutely no fun to play this
position is black but you yank keeps it
yeah it just keeps keeps going and the
game goes on and on without white really
having
eat any substantial progress yeah got
this back but now wyd gained the beep
horn so he has the a pawn to to use but
still this King isn't so safe and the H
porn is also a source of town to play um
it's still very very tricky to play I
mean why does some is still preferable
here due to this more dangerous pawn but
black has a definite counterclaim we can
advance a couple of moves that you could
analyze I mean but then the video is
like three hours if I do that not only
this game but also the others here you
know there's 45 more coming up and you
could easily do a half an hour video on
each of them so need to check yeah this
this is an important point I don't
really understand why h3 is played we
can do that it's not it's not a fatal
error but I didn't really understand why
he played a tree maybe there's something
there was some miscalculation involved
um black could also just just stay put
instead of playing that like that's a
queen juice exchange or Queen Queen
somewhere Quincy age just just stay and
don't do much um yeah this is not not
really helping I mean it's clear that
why does not not taking and allowing
Queen chatter three okay this is not
what nida CH overlooked of course them
cracking g3 but maybe he miss somehow
misjudged what what's coming I mean it's
simply that white will get the H porn
with this maneuver and black has not
really gained
much with it I don't really see what yes
he's given it up but it was a double
porn I mean it's not the end of the
world to give up the porn but didn't it
didn't help and here it's really yellow
already very tricky check I can give a
channel checks term it's it's it's
really a tough to defend note the main
threat Queenie 8 and if you look at this
Queen a form this is just a quite nice
the King has no move and there's a
double threat a black cannot cover both
squares with the Queen it's not possible
and black does not have a check himself
so so quite funny quite funny loss yeah
a charm they porn will who decide the
game always note that the main thread
check yeah and here knowledge resigned
yeah I'm not really sure why you plate
the plate age porn it doesn't really
seem to to bring black any any benefit
so I mean it's difficult anyway you
against the air porn but I think if
black just stays and not does not does
not use the it's all so let's just this
possibility shows that the H porn is
useful on yeah you need to have I mean
maybe you just stay on the g4 here and
always keep 23 as an option so that why
this is tied 2-2 this to the square
yeah this was was probably a much
tougher but giving up the h-bomb didn't
help but in general on the type of
position that he got out of the opening
this is this type of position is just
very a very thankless task to defend
especially considering that like has no
particular compensation for it sometimes
like gets into this or usually it's
black getting into this kind of
relatively passive iqp positions but
with some sort of compensation in terms
of let's say having very active roofs
for example if black was would be lets
say ready to yeah i would have to look
on c8 already in this position on it kim
playbook see to rook c8 entering on the
second rank then you you have some
counter play but it's just not not
happening here all right let's go to the
next game hari krishna against come on
and i must warn you that this is one
just like what just in the last round on
the wrong before that I said that i'm
going to cover the longest game ever on
this channel and this record is broken
by this game easily and this means that
we were looking at more than 100 news um
so this means i need to be quick with
the initial phase of the game we have a
rule no peasant kawana playing this
Bishop c5 fly under you have the line
with many names the card chef variation
the new art angles variation the molar
variation there are many names and it's
one of the main lines of the ruin
nowadays at least on the professional
level you don't see it that much on
non on the amateur level okay this is
one of the main continuations I believe
black is giving up the beep horn and in
return gets very nice active pieces this
is pressure on d4 this is a good pin and
I have checked only briefly the
theoretical background of this this line
really very briefly because there's a
much theory on it and it seems that in
the game this is as the plate number of
times and only here this is a new move
and move 21 yeah well I have some f1
more than 100 moves to cover so it's
it's tricky to to to look at all the all
the points of all this moves in general
what black is trying to do is to get so
much pressure going on d 4 + b2 that
white is unable to to use his extra pawn
he has gained upon but it's not easy to
get to make any headway black very often
gets a pawn back and we see that in the
game after discontinuation yeah not not
so much happening we've got the
repetition and now why destroying with
that form that black is getting
substantial play here against the center
young some trades and at the end black
cami is attacking those two and has some
active pieces still you don't have yeah
regained the pawn yet this is weak but
why does to Bishop so it's not an
especially great opening resolve
probably Black is not in in big trouble
but it's certainly not what car ahead
Ted plant we see that after 597 and the
trade why does trying to turn improve
his his Bishop here and black is going
for for counter play against the beep on
yeah another idea using the pin of the
spawn camp and black just takes takes on
before yet this involves um can you
exchange sacrifice we see this quite in
the in the near future Bishop before
attacking the rook now we played rugby
six Bishop c4 andrew h 5 ER the exchange
Tigers is coming around him let's put
this on the vault we got to this
position where black had regained to be
porn but the white still has this
pressure group takes 26 form for example
is the threat and yeah he played him the
move roof c6 here and this really
involves learn dimensioned sacrifice or
maybe he just just made some Mis
miscalculation it's possible um he
didn't need to do that he could have
played this should be five with this
with this counter play and this seems oh
okay for black after Luke c6 Whitehead
the move Roxy one and maybe he just
overlooked that it's possible if now
like move the bishop let's say here this
Bishop of seven of course and you lose
this exchange under far less favorable
circle
census what like did is he took on c4
maybe he really overlooked that it
wasn't 40 the no time so this was
necessary to give up the exchange and
now play Bishop b5 the yeah the thing is
though yeah like Las the exchange but is
it really losing the game if you look at
it with a computer it gives why the
winning advantage but I'm not so sure
this is some case where the computer is
really not able to evaluate this
fortress type of position correctly I
think it's well it's not it's not giving
it as a clear-cut win like plus three or
something but plus one point three or so
which usually is a win um but here I'm
not sure at all black has really a
fortress type of quality in this
position the rook on f5 is covering f7
which is the main weakness and the night
is nicely anchored and dwight has those
weak pawns i am not sure at all that
this this should be a be a win for white
I think black has very decent two
chances to draw we can advance a bit ago
the check got the trade of Bishops which
does not really ought to the general
evaluation that much it's still a
position where blacks pieces form a nice
fortress type yeah unit and we see that
I can video it once quickly here with
the moves that white is making
absolutely no headway for quite a long
time Black has switched the position a
bit now the night is blocking he and
while he can just stay stay put only a
bit later white tried something too
make any sort of progress not quite sure
it which move this happened I mean this
game is so long i really i really have
no recollection when when it happened or
much later in it so we have a ton of
more moves check this guy this kind of
game is the reason why you really need
to play with increments nowadays um and
in former times that you can easily
happen that white plays like 200 moves
in this position every 50 move advancing
upon and it takes ages and you simply
are not able to make the moves and it's
simply nothing going on yeah here wider
being a bit desperate place plays f5 of
course not not great but it's it's there
simply no progress to be made here black
was picking up the pawn here anyway
Jackie gave up this one and we have a
look trade at least but now we get to
the point where we have rook against
night and pawn and this is really just
completely dead I'm not quite sure to be
honest why harikrishna is continuing for
four more than what moves let's check
yeah he's still playing more than 30
move from here check maybe he wanted to
to you know play his longest game ever
I'm not sure what is personally
recognized in this respect but this is
really completely check check check
let's let's put this on the board in
bullet moti yeah yeah check when to King
were this King young
it's a really a terribly long game I
think what are the main points yeah come
on I wasn't in a bit of trouble out of
the opening but then he regained the
porn here but after some more moves on
move 40 he committed this mistake after
which rook see one um yeah basically one
the exchange but even after that it
seems that check probably white could
not win I mean I'm not one hundred
percent sure but I'm quite sure that
there is no win in this position because
of this fortress type of setup so um
yeah a bit of them sadly lucky draw I
think for kawana wasn't in some trouble
most of the time and defending most of
the time not very much fun to play this
this type of position for so long
alright so let's go to the next game and
this is our own Ian against Wesley cell
aronian the leader of the tournament so
also having a good event so far let's
see what happens oyun with c4 yeah he's
varying between d4c 493 this time in
English opening and so is playing the
goon fault type moves d5 after which
white has a big big choice you can play
many more CF i also have played this
position this wide for a number of times
i played Queen a four-year chap I've
tried queen bee three h4s even move also
interesting and Aronian is playing an
idea that I'm absolutely um not aware of
heads it was new to me interesting you
should reform this is not new of course
takes be takes also a known
fine here white if he really wants to
play very dry game can take with the
pond and play his end game in fact this
is not so it's draw a sure but white can
can can try a bit he's very slightly
very slightly better but ok Aronian was
once to play more complicated chess he
plays b.tech see Bishop g7 and here i
only knew that y term of course can play
on usually does play d4 to transpose to
a normal goon felt but how long it just
does not play before this interestingly
place but should be to c5 yeah black
always needs to be ready for deform but
what just does not play it yeah 96
preventing before now and now he plays
Queen 84 I think this is a quite
interesting way to play and a nice
innovation at least them I didn't know
it and also didn't find any any big on
examples off of this of this play it has
been played before but it's not a
popular line on ok why just delays this
idea that's one point fifty seven and
now Queen a 3m attacking the importancy
five-point like it covers it and now
Ruby one yeah introducing the late
deform advance so we have a good fault
type of position ok ladies moves out but
it's just slightly different and this is
a very typical thing in modern chest
that players are trying to use tricky
move orders to to get two positions time
position types that they know but with a
twist and here wide them i think was
successful to introduce gandu problems
too
to the black player and we see that so
quite quickly got into a position that
was at least uncomfortable he now
exchanged on a three yeah it it's not
it's not a for smooth of course but
black also always must reckon with dtc
5d takes d5 does not to position a very
desirable move but it might be just
technically good attacking the the
bishop on d 7 well he had he had a
complete idea he took and now Bishop g4
this is just increasing the pressure on
the on the pawn deform and it looks very
logical of course yeah and now I'm what
is why it's supposed to do black you're
threatening to take on f3 and take on d4
so white needs to do something about
this pressure dt2 consi five leading to
an opening of the position which is of
course something that wide welcomes
because black will probably take on f3
it's hard to avoid that in the long run
after d takes like captured on c3 this
is think almost forced and now bishop
asics with this possibility so we have
an open position where white i think is
just a bit more comfortable because he's
got the looks in play already just one
or two more 10 p-4 black and it would be
quite equal but this is just not the
case here why does just more active you
know and here oops nope the capture on
b6 is just an annoying annoying point
here if like me treats this is what I
mean attacking the night
so what should like do now here he had
an interesting technical opportunity he
could take on c5 but he didn't do that
some an interesting move of course white
cannot take here because be one hangs
check so a rock to expiate is the move
you need to check but then night p 8
will attack the a6 bishop and make sure
that like is not losing the c3 bishop
this seems okay from like I mean right
can always play something like that but
this is just just very equal so maybe
BTW xe5 was an interesting option whiter
of course does not need to play rook
takes vit can just take here for example
and yeah after there should be two rook
don't know where do you want maybe maybe
see tune I don't know um it seems that
black has good chances to equalize
however he played a different different
mood sleep late Bishop takes a three and
this is what I mentioned before white
will get the bishops now and this is
already not so easy Ned Bishop b2g1 and
bishops III bag of course this position
is quite reduced in terms of pawn count
on the queenside have all queenside
pawns I exchange then black softly will
draw but this is simply not the case why
does just more active yeah King King g2
is a good move to cover every so that
those kind of moves are not happening
with the temple on a three and yeah
Black is just fighting against the
bishops now
he played the capture and it's it's
really hard to to give like some advice
if you look at let's say i whooped you
hate and all move like that wyd can take
yeah rook takes loses to be 60 night
takes probably and then whoopsie one
it's also not nice at all something like
that and now white can can check the
move c6 it's very interesting or I can
also take and take g7 C 6 however is
just stronger directly threatening this
it's it's really a bit bit tricky
already I think Bishop takes f3 really
helped white yeah well he captured and
why just recaptured very hard now to
keep the material e7 and a7r under fire
move like we should be seven for example
it's just so annoying where does the
night go or Bishop b5 for that matter
the end what will probably win one of
the pawns played the bishop before there
should be three of course keeping the
pressure and now see one not exchanging
of course well this is typical way to
increase the pressure maybe five getting
the King involved this is all a benefit
of this zone in for white of this
capture on your three white camel uses
king also quicker in the center still
it's not a lost position for black of
course it's just very uncomfortable to
play that king of eight
and we went to our we reached this
position now um captured on a three of
course this is a technical line now and
Roxy form yeah of course what's
happening now the rook is hanging and
where should it go it seems that rook c7
here is a bit more a bit more stubborn a
defense it's not great or anything but
it's probably a tougher defense than
what Wesley cell were played after for
example group d 3 you should be six
Andrew dc-3 it's also a very nasty
pinion but black has the move night
before to to continue it's not great at
all but it's still possible to continue
the game can have a look at that and
this at the end getting at the e74 White
has excellent winning chances here as
well but in the game he played rugby aid
and after that I think gone blank is
flat-out winning roubaix one essentially
double attack who should be too and look
a to a for this is a funny funny p setup
and a very typical of Romeo and he has a
really a great sense of using his rooks
in an unusual kind of that usual places
it's very rare to see two rooks on the
fifth rank or fourth rank ian worst case
he had a game against navara and I think
2010 or loop yet way had black rooks on
the fifth-ranked really really funny um
yeah the point is this night is a tech
night it doesn't have any any square to
go to relief is only route d6 to defend
it after a five
e 6 and Roxy too there's this additional
possibility introduced attacking the
trap drug and winning an exchange and
material losses are unavoidable here
already the toughest threat of the
toughest defense would have been rupee
form but he played 98 after Bishop e7 a
look ahead and we should be five it's
it's really too much with the trap druke
the bishop is attacked yeah plate we
should be five desperation move after
Bishop e3 here black resigned so get
another win for a long young who's
playing an absolutely outstanding
tournament at the moment he's gotten
rating performance above three thousand
at the moment three thousand and some
points it's close to his all-time rating
racket in the live rating list being on
to 2825 something being clearly than the
world's number two at the moment almost
40 points higher than knocking Ryan
Kramnik a great event so far and turn
let's see if he can continue to to play
at this space okay let's go to the next
game Geary against gal front camera fury
against galfond and here girlfriend is
going for the for the groom felt the
addition to his opening repertoire for
the World Championship match 2012 it's
been a life long run expert on the white
side but preparing for the world
championship match Latin to to take it
up for black now we get one of the the
modern lights where an end game is
reached immediately the main expert in
this line is
cronic on the white side played many
great games with that team also beat
Giri with the slide so maybe this led to
the led to this game the Giri plate
that's wide ok I don't want to go into
so much detail here and focus on the on
the end game Liam after some moves yeah
get a fairly typical endgame position
for this line um I'm really not sure if
you can know if White has a slight edge
or if it's just equal I think it's
probably a just equal and we see a why
couple of moves later Black is putting
pressure on deform and this is the key
move oops not look so quick this is the
key move f5 at the taxi form and the
text deform and white really has no big
choice he needs to play me five and this
transformation I think means that black
shouldn't have any trouble at all
because he will get a night to d5 and
this hampers white five against four
majority so on why does not really have
anything or much to play for first
played H sticks to make sure that
nothing is going to g5 after a couple of
more moves like head has managed to to
get the night to d5 as mentioned and at
first you might think ok maybe black can
even do something because he's got two
against one and potential person but
this pawn of this upcoming past porn is
not really not really a big threat we
see that in the game shop like who gets
this
so we're here we could be six I can take
on g4 it's it's still a finely balanced
position yeah white locating the pawn
this is all yep pretty much
understandable without any big big
comments and end equal it's not not
really a problem for for both sides so
but they keep fighting I mean they could
just agree to draw but continued a bit
probing around and white is having an
idea is trying for this night maneuver
check here we go this is a good try I
mean it seems that with the best play
it's not leading to much but it's it's
interesting okay like took it and here I
move 51 girl fart needed to be precise
and in fact he made a mistake him he
played check Knight f6 check and it
seems that this move really lends him
into big trouble very natural looking
and he should probably play on came to
King to have six with good chances to to
draw it's not even so easy to play but
probably still it wrong but let's look
what happened to our son I have six
because this is very interesting black
cam I gave the check and white needed to
retreat of course cannot cannot go here
check funny self-made ok King back to be
three
I to d3 sorry and now 97 this was the
idea here give you missed his chance 11
of the chances he has one later but he
could have played rope 2 h8 which seems
which seems better just attacking
attacking the the pawn and okay the age
porn if this falls white has a very
strong pattern this seems to win what
you played also keeps an edge but it's
not so convincing b3 is a source of
counter flame yeah
this position is very interesting if you
like to learn to to to have some
challenge you can try to work out in
this position what why it's best
continuation is and if you want you can
pause the video and look a bit for
yourself I'll be quiet for a couple of
seconds yeah he do we have the
opportunity to play the very thematic
move d 5 this would have been very
strong and very traumatic SS mentioned
because it opens up this bishop and the
point is that after 95 again there's
rogue age 8 and this is a big threat
after you could be seven for example you
have Bishop g5 and with this move you
can keep your pawn this wouldn't have
been possible if there still is a pawn
on on default so this is a very
important piece activation and this
should probably win for white it didn't
do that you played the King c4 first
which is not spoiling much but d5 was
stronger on Rudy seven and Group B 6 of
the better defense but it's very tricky
very tricky to play rock d7 castex and
queen bees and king a king bee 396 and
well it's not so interesting in this
position here you can also go for ya for
treating this position as a puzzle why
to play and play and win it's it's not
not difficult now because it's just the
same d 5s again the winner and here I
mean okay if the times are correct i
underst
and that it's not easy with three
minutes on the clock but it's a fairly
easy move to play for for world-class
player because it's a simply so logical
to activate the bishop and one of course
important technical point is that 95 is
losing due to Bishop g7 and this you can
overlook of course it's a really strange
movie detects the ball and different
like takes of course the deform promotes
some bit unusual this motif but there as
mentioned very thematic this is a strong
piece now after the deep on is this
jettisoned yeah after it takes in fact
it's relatively easy why just moves the
king of the board and supports the deep
on combined with this idea it's it's a
very easy win but key we didn't find
that he played the bishop a three and
yeah here again d 5 wins uppity me
simply didn't didn't see the idea it
seems and now this golden opportunity
has passed but in fact relatively
quickly afterwards they agreed to a draw
yeah there's no progress to be made him
d5 was a relatively easy win but okay if
the clock times are correct it's not
easy to play with two or three minutes
on the clock so bit of a lucky escape
for gelfand he was having a really bad
he went he is struggling in most of the
games simply not being in in good shape
alright so next game domingues nakamura
domingues nakum wrong okay
yeah I can world playing the the Berlin
Wall he sometimes does that seems a bit
and yeah a bit a bit strange decision
for such a fighting players not gonna
Robert this is some somewhat one wrong
on conception sometimes of this this
opening it's not a terribly boring
opening if white really hides hard in
the end game it's it's complicated chess
there are only some lines that I really
dull like for instance rupee one this
this kind of stuff is very boring but
the pure end game which we get in the
game we get the absolution main line of
the of the end game this can really lead
to interesting play and we see that this
game is no exception um the mingus is
going for this h3 line which nowadays is
is all the rage white is trying to very
quickly make progress on the green side
this has been played a number of times
also by Nakamura in fact we can go up to
this move f5 here Nakamura only and I
think it was October october2013 just a
couple of months ago he had played c5
yeah against kawana in the european club
cup and it ended in a draw very very
complicated game but at the end ending
in a draw he played a new movie alibi h5
and i'm not sure that it's really an
improvement um to be honest i feel that
this is so complicated that my
relatively limited analysis is not
enough to really assess what's going on
i can say i can show you what I'm what
I'm talking about this is some very very
logical
in my book black attacks those pawns and
he needs to do that white has gained so
much space he needs to attack the pawns
after f6 night x and Knight f3 back this
needs to be covered Nakamura goes for
porn grabbing with night before and
Gregg Zaun c2 and the position that he's
getting right after that is it's very
very tricky and I really don't like it
but of course after age five I mean he
played this this novelty I'm improving
on let's say I'm playing a new move
compared to one of his own games um and
he really must have looked at this
because well this is very logical moves
to kingi 293 all this is basically
forced so he probably had prepared all
this this is also supported by the by
the clock times and if you look at this
Bishop f4 let's just put it on the board
all this is quite forced I mean isn't
this isn't this looking like a very
dangerous position for black I really I
really don't don't think it's it's it's
comfortable to play I mean 95 attacks f7
that's the e-cigs idea there's really
much pressure on like I mean maybe he
needed some some analysis and came to
the conclusion that black hand can
defend that white needs to be precise
earnest in his active play but it turns
out relatively quickly that black has
big problems Bishop d7 not here already
spent some time maybe you can even
debate if this is such a gram
okay 95 and takes on g4 yeah maybe 98 it
looks passive I know but maybe this was
what's the battles the thing that might
happen after that is group takes d7 this
is a very interesting line king cakes
and d6 this is really leading to White's
pieces getting very very active one
point being that 96 is caused by losing
straight away after the check King moves
and after that black is probably losing
those pawns combined with the light on
g6 are winning the game let's so this
was too quick let's just check this
again black probably needs to take with
the pawn and then 95 check I mean this
is like this is whole position feels
like dodging bullets all the time white
again has dangerous pawns active pieces
and black is simply not coordinated it
it's it's not much fun to defend it
seems the best is a five Bishop b5 and
this is the line that I had yeah the no
edge form it's still very very
complicated 96 bishop and for Bishop b6
this could be I know I know I've no one
can take a player 70 this is Lance's
only something else I can move from him
King be seven
or D 7 yeah something like that is a
possibility maybe Nakamura was afraid of
that he played that move but after after
that it gets very tricky it takes and
Bishop g4 yeah again 98 was a
possibility but after Luke h1 this is
just getting very very problematic black
can not take simply because after the
coming Luke h8 he will lose material on
the King side and decisive material oops
yeah like a drive-through gauge sticks
but I don't think it helps them in the
long run let's say hmm yeah maybe this
one covering this this Bishop so that
after let's say hmm King b7 you can take
and move the night yeah this is simply
not not a nice position even that one is
a good move this is attacking all pieces
yeah a black really is in trouble it
took on g4 and now white opal f7 and now
I can yeah even without calculating many
variations you can see that like is
struggling those two pawns are they're
just super dangerous and they also
completely kill off the didn't 58 bishop
it has nowhere to go rue page 5 King
g300 very logical yeah why this wine is
winning in the suppose
and it's doing a decent job of keeping
his his big edge but in fact I advanced
a couple of moves k effect somewhat
later a black was basically forced to do
that to get rid of one of the pawns um a
bit later he is not playing in the most
precise way here um before was a good
idea I think to try to get rid of the
sea porn so that 94 is not a defensive
option he didn't do that it's probably
not a decisive mistake or anything but I
just like the move Jack White still
keeps of his his edge intact but it
later around here here he made a mistake
white um probably should play Bishop b5
here and after let's say 96 play some
slower improving rules let's say I like
Bishop back to c3 for example he played
rook f1 and yeah this just hurts to to a
tactical idea and I cameras obviously a
very good technical player and spotting
and spots those technical defenses you
played this will be 6 check just the
simple check and this is also just
taking on f6 played King g5 and now the
problem is this move Bishop c4 attacking
the rook on f1 and introducing 96 and
yeah white what has problems now he
takes on King to be five and yeah what
now the look is attacked you only have
flu gave to basically and now are some
96 check this is a problem here here
until
King to reform and after night Texas
have an effect they immediately do the
game at this point yeah maybe white
could have looked at this position and
maybe not take on CSM we can look at
that if he plays rook f2 without taking
their slightly 6 check yeah the big
point is white cannot take because J
smooth and black is even winning easily
so black muster black white must move
back with the king let's say here and
now we have six and yeah now we have a
position where black already has got
three pawns for the exchange and maybe
is starting to get ambitious so what
Dominguez was doing with the group takes
his seven as basically killing the game
off to a draw before you even get into
trouble yeah this was a very lucky
escape from that camera but I mean it's
always relative lesson there is luck in
chess but it's also a bit um it's also a
case of defending on tenaciously and
he's certainly doing that all the time
it's really trying to muddy the waters
and try for counter play so well yes
still a game that Dominguez had a good
winning chance and they don't really
like the slide for like it it feels like
is under pressure but I'm no expert on
the on the Berlin Wall I guess it's not
it's not something that wins before so
on something like that otherwise we
would have seen it in the world
championship match so on probably and
this will be played some more times and
it be explored more to to check if black
is really under pressure
alright one game left i'm already above
the one-hour mark but at least i'm not
approaching the two-hour mark there been
times where i could have done that okay
from vainly against report the creative
hungarian GM let's see what is doing in
this game not so much opening creativity
we go to a king's indian and in fact
relatively long theoretical I'd
assessment played numerous times five is
so not a means that i personally like
too much but it's certainly playable
what I don't like about it and Finn
really takes is that it leads to a pawn
structure exactly this pawn structure
where black is not very dynamic on the
on the kingside those pawns they are not
able to do much and white has a very
clear plan of play on the queenside I
mean compared to the classical main line
wide it's never going to get major to
him okay black is immediately reacting
to the before plan is playing c5 himself
and this is important very important
point for vetting out captures on c6 I
think this is really necessary to make
any headway in the game you can of
course just to let say castle but how
are you ever going to open up the the
queenside like a black is a bit passive
but he's got good chances to defend
passively on the queenside the capture
is just more straightforward followed by
before the ideas to play b5 dislodging
this point and then d5 can be a good
square we see that in the game after a
couple of moves that white managers to
gain the d5 square form for a night in
fact in this game I think it always or
for a long time the game was
a bit drifting between somewhat better
for white and about equal when we see
that white has the better structure
that's clear but black's pieces are
quite active he doubled here on the
Bihar putting pressure on the pond and
yeah their ideas to get an ID to deform
the the only very long term that you can
easily forget about is that blacks king
is a bit weak it's at the moment there
are no pieces near it but those pawns
yeah well they they don't they don't go
back and whites king is just far more
secure in comparison to two blacks king
and this will play a role in the game
later okay couple of moves later we see
that black entered on on the second rank
and after group d three he played 90 for
some traits and root d2 in fact I'm here
we have one one of the critical
positions of the game in this position
now report place the move from Queen to
a 6 and this is just a direct I think
direct tactical mistake he probably
should have played yeah I'm much simpler
I mean the Queen only six it covers the
the g4 pond and well you don't want to
play a passive chess and always let's
say stick to the defense of pawns but I
think you just simply should keep it and
maybe play at a queen d7 if you want to
move the Queen Queen a6 just has a
simple problem it took took and here we
go the pot is gone and it's clear that
report didn't just blundered this I
think
um he played d3 probably wanted to play
in the most active a possible way
activating the the pawn may be
introducing Bishop before just not try
to be passive but it simply simply it
does not seem to be enough white white
is better now 27 and now we see what
what I was talking about the King
position white is playing on the light
squares something like that for example
and we see that after Queen g6 97 k
white in fact got the night to to f5 and
yeah we know this is a very strong piece
an idol at five yeah famous pair of
quote with an eye toward f5 I'm
unstoppable we just prefer just probably
true if you run a statistic of course
far off games where he had a night on f5
he probably has won all of them okay b2
and g3 yeah Queen d3 was probably am
even more force well but dg3 is a very
understandable move making some sort of
looked for the King so that you're not
mated on the back rank entire bishop see
323 bishops III also wasn't the best but
blacks player some it's really difficult
to him Queen a seven yeah here the
absolute yeah okay there are more than
one critical points of its game but here
fan really had had a very very big
opportunity to to win the game um the
easiest is is to play e5 and it's really
amazing that he didn't play that the
clock times are not so accurate i know
but if I the such an obvious move I
really don't understand why you didn't
play it it's a
threatening 97 with the deadly meeting
attack and black has no no nothing
absolutely no defense to that and it's
very easy to see I don't I don't really
know why he didn't didn't play that um
that sets for example if like takes just
two yeah to put it on the ward yeah it's
as really its aim check check white wins
the Queen this is why Queenie a7 also
was very unlucky Matt's unprotected um
so if I've just fled out wins and yet
time on the clock I don't I don't really
know where why did why didn't um and
yeah blacks idea of course do you need
to check this as well if white takes on
C 3 flex idea was was to promote even
this is interesting for white I hit
Queen takes be to you can play and
you're still havin arranging a tech yeah
Queen d 8 and then something something
like that Luke d1 Queen age five and but
ok this is probably winning as well but
it's it's simply not not relevant
because if I've just flat-out winds and
it's not difficult he played a look T 1
and the fun thing is this is also
winning with various lines after Bishop
before again he five is winning and he
played it you played it Queen f7 check
check going to Queen deform yeah quite
for a long time widest winning but he
simply does not yeah he does not really
finish finish him off in this position
for example after twin f6 he played
Queen d7 check there was also just
Queenie form intending 95 and I don't
really see a defense to
then black black probably will sack the
exchange to just continue but it's it's
winning for white okay well between
these have endure should also win but
it's it's it's more complicated yeah
g-force a quite nice defensive try but
also this ultimately should not be
enough to draw from Vinnie now played
Quincy a check card mistaken yes and
this is again a bit strange week or so
you can take it and it wins Queen f3
Jack King h3 it's just a deadly attack
here but I cannot take yells mate check
check check no that's so check check
check mate quite nice using the pawn to
care what they have seven square black
you cannot take on d1 he needs to play
something like Weiner five and then
white continues with the guy using a
deep on he can give checks first check
here for example yeah maybe in check
somewhere I don't know it's a it's it's
all good for white maybe King g6 and now
where is it is seven I'm not sure yeah
what can you can play seven now we have
geek a place I've now intending the two
queen of course and black has no move
yeah it's it's quite strange she's
simply not playing the ones that win but
it's easy to to say after after the game
when you can all check it with a
computer and it just mercilessly
calculates all those lines
King g7 check and no e7 yeah well this
is clearly worse in comparison whiter
it's giving up the phone for the deep on
and now Bishop g5 and this is the real
problem at the end of the slide that
white has no way to get out of this pin
and from a position where white was
almost meeting um we have gotten an end
game this is really the best line where
white is one who has one upon but it's
it's just it's just the wrong what can
you do white can try and you try it for
a bit but it's a draw simply because
black has a very active configuration
you on them on the Kings side chapter
yeah okay move like that will never win
so you need to give up the pawn and here
black has enough counter play he played
the slightly strange move King age five
this is I didn't really understand
because while h5 is drawing very easily
using the h-bond but King edge five
ropes sorry King at shriver while being
a bit strange um still should draw I
think and and it did draw it was
relatively quick after that we had a
couple of moves check check yes there's
simply no no progress to be made um so a
game well then really easily could have
won at various points but yeah it's
really it's really easy in analysis you
still need to do it with the clock the
clock running so on bit bit lucky escape
for a report who wasn't in big trouble
alright i hope you enjoyed the coverage
of the games i think they all had their
hat their points
and were interesting thanks for watching
I'm your bed girl I think tomorrow
there's not another rest day tomorrow
with the round seven thanks for watching
until then bye